that was Gordon oh well Sami uh pick my
nose
[ __ ] it hey what is going on with you
two
now have you self-esteem issues is a
natural part of life right you wake up
you're having a shitty day someone you
love tells you your face looks like the
Winkle dad's butthole and your breath
smelled like and I'm filled with Indian
food my [ __ ] yeah but for me growing up
I never really had too many self-esteem
issues or never really more than the
average person would experience but what
I found that for me a very serious
relationship is that this is apparently
a god thing guys the girls deal with
their self-perception in very different
ways ladies in case you didn't know most
guys apparently don't have self-esteem
issues how we look at ourselves in the
mirror when we wake up in the morning
it's the same every day it is too [ __ ]
cooter you too [ __ ] not this big what
experiences taught me with the women
that I've been with is that we as men
love ourselves too much guys could use a
little self-esteem issues because by now
our self recession is completely off
here's some true [ __ ] you know I didn't
almost fat until last year yep that's a
six-pack my personal friend tell me I
was like two biscuits away from a c-cup
but I listen that [ __ ] ladies think
about this for a second why do you think
that clubs you always get hit on my
dudes that you know are way under your
league that's because what you see is
not how we feel you see this I see this
if you have not realized it by now it's
a simple matter of self-worth it's just
that with men you know we just take a
little too far it's funny with women
because I found out that you ladies have
something called fat days but both of
you men out that don't know what a fat
day is a fat day is a day month or week
of the year where your girls will feel
fat no matter what and it does not
matter how you think she looks she just
feels fat and we're men [ __ ] up on
this is by not acknowledging that she
failed this way if you were to remember
one thing from this video remember this
it is your job on those days to make her
feel beautiful not to tell her she's
overreacting babe we're overreacting
yeah you will get [ __ ] up and if you
do say this tool you might end up in a
situation where she gets something
called no puss Elias which is Greek for
you and getting up with it remember
fellas it has nothing to do with the way
she actually loves she feels this way
she got back topples honest all she sees
ladies you also have to realize that
your guys probably doesn't understand
you because guys don't have this [ __ ]
you don't that part of the day right
before you leave but she looks in the
mirror and she just could takes the [ __ ]
out of herself but I obviously came out
of a butthole cuz I want like [ __ ] you
know while I know this [ __ ] is true
because even if we say the exact same
words the way we say is completely
different my God my God look at my fat
ass why do you think what guys get
challenged we always have to defend our
honor it's because that's how important
every [ __ ] guy thinks that they are
even the biggest governor has pride as a
human being and a man pride for what
some of you pieces of [ __ ] out there
what have you done for your self-esteem
to be so damn high you have besmirched
my honor you're a [ __ ] criminal but I
still gotta the point is if the guy out
there who is the lowliest scumbag on
earth thinks that he is that important
love himself that much maybe you should
too and by the way I'm only telling you
this because I've made this mistake
multiple times my testicles have been
punched so hard it's like coming out
inside of my mouth I did that that look
like a dick in my mouth
hey what is going on YouTube if you've
noticed that we now have videos every
Wednesday and Sunday again so make sure
that you check it out Wednesday and
Sunday and for those of you out there
that I do this channel click and
subscribe because I'm gonna pig in any
[ __ ] that makes jokes like this
ah ha ha anyways you guys see you guys
this Wednesday and Sunday peace out I
love you touch me feed me and it got a
little serious would that baby always
get hit on my dudes that you mmm puberty
girl the guys tend to deal with their
self-perception in precision put the
[ __ ] of perception we gonna make it
worse today huh what's up cadet faze you